♪～
みんなが知っている通り、
僕は かなりコンビニが好きです。
自分でご飯作ることもないし、すっごいコンビニが好きなんですけども、
今回は、サークルKサンクスさんの唐揚げ弁当がリニューアル
したというお話しを 聞きました。
こちらですね。 ちょっと開けてみてもいい？
ほーほーほー
あ、やばい
匂いが いい。
から揚げっていうのはね、味付けにすごく時間がかかるらしいんですよ。
家だと時間がかかる作業を しっかりやって、
時間をかけて作ったのが、こちらの「から揚げ弁当」のから揚げです。
すりおろしリンゴや ダイ…ああ、大根は使われてねえな。
すりおろしリンゴや ニンニクなども 使ってあって、とてもおいしい味わいになっているらしいです。
サークルＫサンクスの 新しいから揚げの作り方、
僕 なんと、何とですね、
こっそり、聞いちゃったわけなのだ。
新しい「から揚げ弁当」のから揚げ の大事なポイントはね、醤油とね作り方なんすよ。
あ、言えねえぞ。
企業秘密だから言えないんですけども、僕はこっそり聞いちゃったんで、
今日は、ちょっと 僕がんばってですね、この
サークルKサンクスの新しい唐揚げ弁当の
唐揚げを、
俺のこの手で
俺の力で
作ってみようと思います。
僕が作った から揚げと サークルＫのから揚げ、どっちがうまいかっていうね、
これで俺のほうが うまかったらね、俺はスゲエよ。
という訳で、実際にそのサークルＫサンクスのから揚げ弁当を 僕自身ちょっとがんばって作ってみて、比較してみようと思います。
ちなみにこの俺様、から揚げは作ったこと…
無い！！
これでまずしっかり味を覚える
いただきます、唐揚げ。
♪～
！！！
味わいが 深いな。
もうね、ご飯との組み合わせが本当にうめえ。
あっ、うまい。肉汁感がすっげぇうめえ。
OK…OK…味は覚えた、味は覚えたぞ。
作り方も分かってるんで、作れる！
という訳で、早速作ってみようと思います。
♪～
（パン！）まぁ！天才の俺なら、一瞬で作れると思うぜ。
まずは肉だ。まず肉を切ることから始めよう。
包丁が無いなあ…これでいいや。
これ水洗い しなきゃいけないんだっけ？
そういうなんか食べ物事情が 俺には分からん。
やべぇ、まな板が無いから、このお皿でやろう。
これ手 洗わなきゃ！（水の音）
よし出来た…こんなもんでしょ。これ、から揚げの大きさ。
あ！おい！あのーーー
料理動画じゃないから！
とりあえず、同じものを作ればいいんだよ。
2つ目、3つ目、はい4つ目！
まず切る時点で疲れる…ああ、何でもないっすよ！
全然 楽しい。
5つ確保
とりあえず、このお肉に味付けをするために、ショウガとかをぶち込んどきゃいいよ、多分。
え、こんなに入れていいのかな…
ニンニクも負けじとちょっと、、、
コンソメ！やっ！
コンソメ！…あっ
こんなに入れていいの？
おろしリンゴは どうすればいいの？
（リンゴをかじる音）
おろしリンゴか…リンゴおろすの面倒くさいな。潰します。
（木づちを打ち付ける音）
やぁ、大根おろしがあった。
（リンゴをおろす音）
はい、完成しました。これが、から揚げの味付けです。
ここでポイントなんですけど、実はこのサークルＫサンクスの「から揚げ弁当」、
醤油が地区によって種類が異なります。
東海地区、関東の北、九州地区、関西地区
俺は静岡だから、東海地区だな。
こっちのたまり醤油だ。たまり醤油を使います。
（醤油を注ぐ音）
OK OK…ワア～
おおお！お！お！いい匂いする。
OK OK. グッティ グッティ
味をちゃんとね、染み渡らせることが大事です。
（油を注ぐ音）
（袋を開けようとする、ガサガサ音）
ワアアアアアアア～！
（点火音）
これでもう入れていいのかな。
熱！アア！
あああ！
あああああ～！
（から揚げが揚がる音）
え！やばい！やばい！どうすればいい？！え？え？
どうすればいい？え？どうすればいい？あ～！助けて！！
わあっ！えっ、燃っ、おっ、えっ、
今、燃えたよ。
なんとかしなきゃ！なんとかしなきゃ！
（油が跳ねる音）
熱う～！！！！
♪～（悲しげな曲）
ううっ
まぁ、けど見た目的には、ちょっと微妙に違うかな
ちょっと揚げすぎた感じはあるんですけども、まぁ作り方は基本的に同じなので、味は多分同じだと思います。
いただきます。
（咀嚼音）
あ、うまい！
サークルＫサンクスのから揚げの味までとは言えないんですけども、
まあ！初めてにしては上出来だと思います、この出来上がり感。
ちょっと本家と比較してみよう。
パッと見…同じじゃ...ない...ですかね…
はい！という訳で、今回 サークルＫサンクスさんの「から揚げ弁当」を自分で唐揚げ作ってみたんですけども、
大変だね
おいしいし、まぁ作ろうと思えば作れたんですけども…
非常に時間が かかりました。
あの動画でなんかカットしてあるんですけど実質もう1時間以上かかってますからね。
何か文句ある？！
このおいしい味をねサークルKサンクスの唐揚げ弁当だったら
すぐ！お店で食べれるのでとてもおすすめです！
そして何と！
今回このサークルＫサンクスさんと僕のこのタイアップチックな感じなんですけれども、
はじめしゃちょーのシールが、何と、何とですね！
サークルKサンクスの今回紹介した「から揚げ弁当」に僕のシールが貼ってあります。
あたかも、俺が作ったようにね。
なんでよかったらね、
サークルKサンクスに行って、僕のシールと
唐揚げ弁当チェックしてみてください
「から揚げ弁当」の詳しい情報は、動画の説明欄にあります。 よかったらチェックしてみてください。
本当においしいんで、よかったらぜひ食べてみてください。
から揚げ弁当の 革命だぜ
じゃあな！
♪～
やっぱ俺には…自炊は、無理だ。